[Music]
there's no relationship
we just see you when we want to be you
and that's it you can't say what you're
saying
[Music]
is it good you have five friends how are
you not too bad
you're right all right warm
yeah what about you yeah not too bad are
you looking for looking forward to this
yeah of course if your conversation now
it would have been 10 years ago well
it's still the same to me
i don't see i don't see anything
well
there are several things that have
changed in there trophy wins well i'm
sure okay so
nothing has changed so well there's a
lot of things to change we'll get into
it if it's not trophies i don't see
what's changing okay well it's gonna be
a short conversation
league positions are not trophies why
not okay arsenal wanted the north london
derby postponed because they were scared
three two one
only time
ever i can't believe it you know what
you're going to do
firstly
you're in our dressing room so tell me
everything we're doing arsenal was too
afraid
of course afraid of course we are white
foreign
the actual white flowers symbol of
cowardice oh really well you should know
that well what why is we whenever we
already see blazing on your coverage you
should know what the white the white
yeah the white isn't it isn't quite
color white it doesn't matter
this was the first time a team in the
north london library is
a game that's as significant as the
north london derby yes you didn't show
up we didn't show up
with your football club because they
have embarrassed you the only thing that
you'll never forget the only thing that
can embarrass embarrassment is when we
don't be totally that's the only thing
that doesn't you should be embarrassed
i'm not embarrassed what i'm laughing at
is that we didn't tell them no it's not
we didn't turn it up to a friend you're
worried about the result no we didn't
why wouldn't you be worried about what's
nice about it
it's not like it's not like somewhere
where you don't show up we already told
the league that we don't have a team we
have cognitive lies like so hold us also
you can
send the players out alone literally the
day after you send mario out on loan to
italy who pablo murray right
yeah he's going online yeah that's right
it's a flamingo yeah
ainsley went to um robert so if you
don't have players why are you sending
them out alone because you didn't want
to fulfill this picture she didn't know
he was going to get clumped clubs by
who's first the thing about it is that
the point is
to the north london against your
fiercest rivals well it's not fair
there's not a topic please don't say
that first of all
our fairest are not top of the title
they are chelsea
liverpool and manchester united pirates
you can't choose that this is the
weakest of our relationship we can no no
there is no relationship there's no
relationship
we just see you when we want to beat you
and that's it you can't say what you're
saying i'm setting you exactly i'm
certain exactly that's what i'm saying
we don't we don't we don't worry about
you you hate chelsea modern tottenham
uh i don't hate anyone
i'll tell you two ways
chelsea the most annoying team for me
with fans are match united so i laugh
all the time when they go get dissed
because they're always so obsessed with
myself i don't know what to say to this
song you're supposed to be like
we the northland davies is one of the
most significant games in the world
in the world there isn't there isn't
there's no name for the game that
arsenal and champions
but there's no history between tottenham
arsenal and chelsea what happens on the
pitch and this is the crux this comes to
the crux of it is arsenal fans are more
obsessed about whether or not that's
about nothing about what happens on the
pitch that's the most important thing to
you right now i get it if it's obsessed
it's the truth but everything but i'm
saying it's every time there's a there's
a loss there's a complete meltdown at
your football and there's not enough
time when you no no no
no it's near a significant okay so when
hurricane was in bed in bad form there
was no meltdown
no
you you tried to call us cowards
we're not cowards cowards don't her
cowards don't have an invisible team how
do i win the most overcome cameras don't
win the league twice at whiteout name i
understand football rivalry but game is
open
because you were worried about what
would happen no let me say when i was
afraid let me say afraid
why didn't you show up say if i'm afraid
would i be wearing this
no not you as a person your club
we're not afraid of anything
you're i'm you're being forced to answer
this question because it's not a force
all day no no no no what i'm saying so
i'm putting this to you because
your club didn't show up right we didn't
should have you know we should we could
you could beat us a hundred times in a
row it wouldn't be as embarrassing as
not showing up
we're not embarrassed we're not
embarrassing
i would defend everything that the club
does which is right i would defend
everything that i got this was not right
no you couldn't but you could no one
else is saying something but you can say
that you can say that ty this is this is
the greatest gift that arsenal's that
our arsenal football club's ever given
to tottenham what's that if you didn't
show up we were always one of those
coward fc well but that's right but
that's fine and you can sit there but
there will be songs about this and by
whom
i suppose
yeah you will why would we care
your songs mean nothing to us only when
it's the songs about where a great team
your songs mean nothing to us why would
we care that's what i'm saying why would
we care what you think you know do you
care what we think
uh i care the fact that you do you hate
chelsea yeah i generally do you okay i
didn't say i hate chelsea
i said chelsea the bigger game
do you do you can do you care what we
think do you care i just what i mean do
you care what we think yes or no
yeah no you don't know that you're like
you're lying you're lying it's actually
you're lying it's a shame you can't take
a night detective you're lying i don't
think you're lying i'm telling the truth
you're not telling the truth look at you
you're looking away you're not you
from my club if tom gonna call us a
coward let's stand there tottenham get
your medals out we get our trophies out
we'll see your cowards on go on then
call us a coward prove it did you call
someone no it doesn't matter if you call
someone to tell you there's less
[Laughter]
spurs will finish above arsenal this
season
three two one
you can't you can't you can't just what
i can't walk but i know you've made it
abundantly clearly i can't offend
arsenal at all costs but there are some
there's there needs to be some parameter
forever
you can't strongly
so so you're so sure
all right look
in order to try and get get this close
like to try and soften you a little bit
i don't know let's go agree and you'll
go disagree no i've got a strongly
disagree
you're carnage
family
what i know about finishing above you in
the league yeah i know about winning
what's your point well my point is the
question is whether or not who's going
to finish above hood exactly
no there's not people
this is the truth according to me but
what i'm saying is in order to have like
a proper
conversation a little bit you've got to
give a little bit of ground because i
can't say that he said it's not true you
could say whatever i like
there's no proper conversation there's
no proper conversation because you're
not even on our level so
i'm sorry we must be we've finished
you've six times
which is more than you in the premier
league all right which is more than you
and even lester can't even say anything
to us nothing they can't say anything to
us even though they've won the league
and they wonder if they can't be each
other even they can't talk to us so what
makes your vehicle talk to us
this is one of the most exhausting
conversations i've ever seen
but what did you expect did you expect
an easy ride against
the thing is fundamentally there's
nothing i can say because you're always
going to back arsenal regardless
well regardless in the fact that if
we've done something that i think goes
over the top then i can't i don't
understand so you mean
um not really i don't know i don't want
him to say yes yeah of course cersei
doesn't hate us and now he likes people
i don't hate anyone i don't know no no
just forgive me
of course of course of course the fact
that they've allowed us to win the
league twice at white house i mean
without toppling there would be there
would be no arsenal so you know i mean
we were we came into there we came
that's something we can agree on come on
well i i won't click your glasses
because we did we we
moved on to your territory so you know
i shouldn't have to convince you of this
our rival is more significant than the
little spat you had with chelsea a few
years back well i suppose it is but i
just think i'd see tulsa has a bigger
rival that's what i'm saying all right
man for man
arsenal have a better team currently
than spurs
three two one
laughing about meaning if you paired up
every single player yep that there
wouldn't be a single player that gets in
the arsenal team
so what you're saying
that's planned for man in it if that's
where the quest if that's what you think
i'm saying
i'm i'm prepared to go with that
what i'm prepared to go with if that's
what you think i'm saying because you
seem to be able to read my mind so
sorry what are you saying
what i'm saying is exactly that
i think there isn't a single there's not
a single
player that will get into the arsenal
team yeah only only one that's going to
help us win i don't know how is it
if you not a single one of our players
well lorries doesn't get in the rams now
kane doesn't get in above any of your
forwards nope
this is pointless this is completely no
that's alistair mcgowan that's a good
shot
it's a good shot alice armstrong sorry
he's controlled
um that that's nonsense ty he's not he
can't defend that you can't defend
himself he's not sure if you truly
believe kane doesn't get into the
arsenal team then everything you said is
nonsense
what did i say you said i just said does
ken get into any of your front three
positions and you said no that's not
not there isn't another single human
being on earth
madness madness also another fantastic
group my favorite was baggy trousers but
anyway no one else in the world believes
that but youtube no one else in the
world no one there isn't tell me
anything find me one other person who
believes that harry kane doesn't get
into this first team there isn't anyone
he does first who's you he doesn't get
to the first team did you say awesome
sorry sorry look you're you're
deflecting and it's good i've been
defending nothing i'm sorry doesn't get
in nope
i'm sorry no no no it's not enough i
mean it's that's nonsense i mean the
last thing
is there's gonna be people in the
comments who can say whatever they want
but they don't have a dog in the fight
right yeah well so they say they could
say whatever they want they could say
whatever that's what i'm saying
previously you you said that maurice
wouldn't get in the arsenal yeah at the
moment
we'll elaborate on that
okay currently better than you guys
because aaron has actually been
absolutely incredible i raised joris i
think he's a great goalkeeper by the
moment aaron is on beautiful i think
he's been incredible have you by your
own admission don't watch suddenly so
you don't actually know i don't know
i know that's true well i know what i
know well i know it's true that laurie
is not playing better than
that's what i know for true i i mean
look if you if you look at who you'd
want long term next two three years then
you're going to choose a world cup
winning captain what's wrong with that
one what's wrong with that one in your
own words
yeah okay and how many haven't really
got two relegations yes and i'm sorry
just picking up world cups yeah welcome
you're picking him because he plays for
arsenal that's what he's doing welcome
world cup winning maurice who has not
won a trophy at tottenham even though
he's been there for 10 years so
but
on that on that note right
you're saying you'd rather have
lacazette play for arsenal absolutely
he's doing it at the moment than harry
kane absolutely he did that at the
moment
yeah but that's madness again what's
madness
no one chooses
man city didn't come in for lacazette
and
alexander's winning cup right sure
eye for a player might be slightly
better than yours
maybe i'm not saying that i think i
don't know what you think either so
you're saying because man city didn't
come in for alexander i should want
harry kane instead of him no i'm saying
that you're i'm saying that surely you
would want if if he wasn't the tottenham
player you'd want the best players
playing for your football club
absolutely right allegedly we're
allegedly going through
no one's coming for us it doesn't matter
would you be no one's gonna have to say
allegedly
i don't believe anything until it
happens so he's just small rumors the
thing about is that you're saying that
i'm sorry i look at our team i look at
thomas team and i'm sorry i don't want
anyone in obviously i respect that
i don't want any
you're right i don't want any any answer
the thought of an arsenal player playing
for spurs makes me sick well in this
instance for the purpose of answering
this question i can rise above the
rivalry and suggest that there were
there are arsenal players that would get
into the top notes okay
yeah i mean it's just
doing our jobs reason why we're here
i mean uh
you know there are there are i don't
want to list players
okay
[Music]
it's just logic in it
i wouldn't want him because he's a
gooner
but
just on the right side we've got a bit
of an issue we need to solve him and he
would we would solve it should he come
into the team whatever preparedness
[Applause]
spurs
are the biggest bottle jobs in the
premier league
three
two
one
i mean
go on
what are the jobs
i mean
look i'm not i i can't just
we are we are well we are aren't we we
have fought wow
i didn't expect i'm not just going to go
on a run about spur they're big where
there are bigger bottle jobs out there
than the fact is we have we have bottled
it a lot we have cool that's where you
want this i don't know what to say i
can't say anything we haven't won
anything so you can
one we win something then we'll i might
have a different thing to say but
you know i still
would much rather follow tottenham than
anybody else so
i mean we didn't bottle a game with
football it's all i'd say yeah you but
you bought you bought everything else so
that's all right that's okay you bought
trophies haven't you look fundamentally
there's some things you can't
argue against and spurs have that just
the evidence is there in the last 10
years especially
that
we've continuously bottled major moments
champions league final uh
not beating leicester in a finishing
third in the two years races you look so
i'd like to say oh is that what we say
maybe not maybe not then i don't know if
i don't know anything everything i
thought i knew about arsenal as i don't
um yeah
you know there's that if we've
countless semi-finals it's frustrating
it's frustrating and there's nothing
much i can say other than
then there is significant evidence to
suggest that tottenham do bottle big
occasions but it won't be forever
how long would it be i don't know ages
probably but i don't know
let's just hold on to the positives well
i think he'll be for every person
brilliant well i think that's something
we can agree on no do not drink my
gloves
not enough to put rams daily into this
because
he's lit through his you know he's
been a bit flappy this
ram still no um
that's it and that is
yeah put it back
wait listen man i'll back my team 100.